il paraît qu'au 19e on voyait
fréquemment ce genre de scènes sur le
vieux port c'est même devenu aujourd'hui
une danse folklorique et la fricassée
finances qui symbolise une dispute de
couple
généralement dans la rue ou sur le port
de marseille à l'époque 1830 et qui
finit par bien se terminer
ce sont tous les sortants marseille ses
personnages d'argile inspiré des figures
du petit peuple est créée peu après la
révolution
au fil du temps ces figurines de plâtre
or façonner la chronique des petits
métiers autour de la canebière ne
m'attirent sur le futur que si on
n'avait pas de racines
voilà c'est dit et d'autres avantages et
tradition c'est qu'elle remplace le
calendrier sur la canebière l'arrivée
les santonniers annonce l'effet de noël
et leur défilé raconte l'histoire de la
cité phocéenne la ville des villages et
marseille ses côtés convives invités
l'estac lui dresser estac yens mais les
santonniers ce moderniste aussi aux
côtés des bergers provençaux qui raconte
la naissance de jésus
on trouve les héros de pagnol des
vedettes de cinéma
et quant au truculent maire de marseille
qui ne rate pas une fois il cherche
encore son personnage dans mes
adversaires politiques auraient dit que
je suis leur avis moi ma foi je me
verrais dans n'importe quel personnage
du moment qu'ils les provençales sauf le
petit jésus dans la crèche
la foire aux santons de marseille est la
plus ancienne de la région et pour
beaucoup c'est ici que commence le noël
provençal
l'achat de blé on prépare ce fait la
création à mes temps d'éteindre la
relève est donc prête
l'immuable foire aux santons de
marseille a encore un bel avenir devant
elle